are you ready to embark on a journey
into the world of azure choosing Azure
certification is a smart move in today's
Tech Driven Landscape with various
levels of certifications to match your
expertise azour offers a clear learning
path to the success whether you're a
beginner or a seasoned Pro AOS road map
provides structured guidance to master
the cloud platform
ensuring you're equipped with the skills
and knowledge needed for a thriving
career in the digital age discover the
reasons to choose asure certification
explore the different certification
levels and follow the learning path that
aligns with your goals so first of all
let's understand why to choose Azure
certification Azure certification holds
immense value in today's technology
driven World here are some compelling
reasons to consider a your certification
first is enhanced career opportunities
as your certification demonstrates your
expertise in cloud computing and open
doors to a wide range of career
opportunities certified professionals
are in high demand as organizations
increasingly adopt a jaw for their Cloud
infrastructure second is industry
recognition Azure certifications are
globally recognized and endorsed by the
industry they validate your skills and
knowledge giving you a Competitive Edge
in the job market third one is increased
earning potential so the certified Azure
professionals earn on an average of 15%
more than their non-certified
counterparts Azure certification
showcases your proficiency and can lead
to better job prospects and higher
salaries so if you are interested in
becoming an Azure certified professional
then consider simply learns Azure Cloud
architect Masters program Azure Cloud
architect Masters program will help you
master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
technology solution
Implement workloads and Security in
Azure creating and deploying apps in
aure and securing data in Azure now who
should take this program fresh graduates
who are intent on taking the plunge into
the job market secondly professionals
with less than 2 years of experience who
are working in either technical or
non-technical job roles and want to
shift to the cloud so what are you
waiting for enroll now get certified and
get ahead all right so the Microsoft
certific ations are rule based and come
under four levels so now let's have a
look at different levels of Azo
certification first is fundamental
certification Azure fundamentals
certification is an entry-level
certification designed for individuals
new to Azure it provides a foundational
understanding of azure Services Cloud
Concepts security and compliance this
certification is ideal for beginners and
non-technical professionals the the
certification that comes under
Foundation level is Microsoft certified
Azure
fundamentals Azure data
fundamentals aure AI fundamentals so
these three Microsoft certifications
comes under fundamental certifications
all right now next is associate
certifications so associate level
certifications are intended for the
individuals with some experience in
Azure these certifications validate
skills in specific Azure rules such as
such as Azure administrator aure
developer and aure AI engineer associate
level certifications demonstrate
Proficiency in implementing managing and
securing Azure Solutions the
certifications that comes under
associate level certifications include
Azure administrator associate Azure
developer associate Azure security
engineer associate Azure data engineer
associate Azure network engineer
associate Etc other than these there are
some more certifications that comes
under associate levels certifications
all right now coming to the expert
certification expert level
certifications are designed for
individuals that are experienced who
specialize in specific areas these
certifications include aure Solutions
architect expert Azure devops Engineer
Expert and Azure security engineer
expert expert level certifications
showcase Advanced skills in designing
implementing and managing aure Solutions
at an expertise level now coming to the
speciality
certifications so speciality
certifications in Azure offer
specialized expertise in areas such as
sap workloads and Azure iot development
these certifications does not have any
prerequisites allowing professionals to
directly pursue and showcase their
skills in these specific domains the
certifications that comes under this
category includes Windows Virtual
desktop specialty Azure for sap workload
specialty iot developer
specialty so these are the three
speciality certifications there are few
more that you can
explore all right now coming to the
Azure certification learning
path to embark on a successful Azure
certification Journey it is essential to
follow a well structured learning path
Microsoft learn a treasure Trove of
knowledge provides comprehensive
resources and modules to guide you
through this exciting certification
Expedition here's a suggested learning
path to help you navigate the your
certification
landscape so first start with Azure
fundamentals lay a strong Foundation by
beginning your Azure certification
Journey with the Azure fundamental
certification this certification act as
a compass introducing you to the Core
Concepts and services that azour offers
it covers topics such as cloud computing
models Azure architecture core Azure
Services security privacy compliance and
Trust by obtaining this certification
you gain a solid understanding of A's
fundamentals setting the stage for
further
exploration second is choose a role
based certification based on your career
goals and interest select an associate
level certification that aligns with the
desired aure rule this step is like
choosing the perfect vessel to sail
through the Azure
sees there are various role based
certificat ation available such as Azure
administrator associate Azure developer
associate and Azure AI engineer
associate each certification focuses on
specific skills and knowledge required
for that role by pursuing a role-based
certifications you dive deeper into the
Ines of azure services and gain
expertise in your choosen area third one
is gain hands-on experience Azure is not
just a theory it's a practical platform
that demands hands-on experience
Microsoft learn provides interactive
labs and sandbox environments akin to a
training ground where you can gain
practical experience with Azure services
this hands-on experience will be Compass
guiding you through the Ines of azure's
features and
functionalities by working on real world
scenarios and completing Hands-On
exercise you develop the skills
necessary to implement and manage Azure
Solutions effectively fourth one is
explore Advanced certifications
once you have obtained an associate
level certification consider setting
your sites on expert level
certifications these certifications
showcase your ability to design and
Implement complex Azure Solutions like
conquering unchartered territories
Advanced certifications include Azure
Solutions architect expert Azure devops
Engineer Expert and Azure security
engineer associate expert these
certifications require a deeper
understanding of azure services es
architecture and best practices by
pursuing Advanced certification you
demonstrate your expertise in navigating
the most challenging Azure Landscapes
and becoming a trusted Azure
professional so this was about the
learning path to become a Azure
certified professional through this
video session you have gained valuable
insights and skills for success in Azure
Cloud World keep exploring azure's vast
capabilities and watch your career soon
stay curious and continue your journey
towards becoming an aor exp expert all
right with that we have come to the end
of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really help you all thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge do domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here